we're all familiar with the standard
Christmas characters got Santa you got
the elves you got the reindeer there is
one Christmas character character it's
been around like a thousand years who
still has not caught on this is real
he's originally from Austrian folklore
simply known as the Krampus you probably
have heard of him he's a demon who comes
around at Christmas snatches up naughty
children stuffs him in his basket so he
can eat them later on
that's what Krampus does the guy eats
children yeah yeah
yes I'm making a brave stay that was a
brave thing to do sir whole crowd how do
I feel about that one guy one guy had
the courage so he eats kids it's crazy
yeah I can't imagine how Krampus ever
expected to catch him as like a
Christmas staple but here's what I'm
hearing the Krampus has made a real
effort to now soften his image he got a
really good PR team right here in Los
Angeles
now we had him on last week because he's
trying to show the new softer Krampus
yeah yeah it didn't go so well okay but
he wants another chance he says he's
really trying to soften his edges be a
kinder gentler Krampus so please welcome
the Krampus
[Applause]
Thank You cloning it's great to be that
great to be back
happy holidays Merry Christmas and Happy
Hanukkah
the to everyone oh you know that's I
gotta say that's very nice very nice
gesture and it looks like you're making
an effort to soften your image Craig oh
yes yes I I truly am and it feels like
the right time because lately I notice
the American people are more willing to
forgive and and even embrace some
downright despicable characters
wouldn't you agree pasta lovers
everywhere yeah
all right chef Mario Batali yeah because
of the allegations against what
allegations like I just think he's an
insufferable pompous ass three months to
get a table at moat so give me a break
take it easy take it easy
Krampus look none of what you've said
changes one simple fact the fact that
you kidnapped children and then eat them
that is just unacceptable oh don't be so
close-minded Conan I've got a new show
on Hulu that will make a child of or out
of any one child over rolek Billy
welcome to take cares nurseries and
playgrounds
[Music]
everyone welcome to take care of
nurseries and playgrounds craps is here
on my way to sunny Malibu California to
drop in on a trendy little daycare
center that's apparently been a huge hit
with the locals let's go and here we are
dolphins break daycare center now let's
head inside and take a peek at the local
cuisine this is the lovely Karen the
owner and I gotta say Karen you've got
some beautiful babies well thank you
very much we like to keep them
entertained and engaged now I heard that
the children here none of that eat any
sugar is that true that's right
yes no sugar no additives all of our
snacks aren't organic Oh
fantastic and that definitely affects
the flip nothing let's take out the bag
so these are all free-range children I
guess we really encourage them to run
and play
yeah and that affects the my ability I'm
sorry are you here to drop off the child
or pick up pick up I didn't know that
was an option but family they also do
takeout yes so to literally but
definitely worth it
dolphins break daycare center in Malibu
gets the Krampus kissing quality Wow
till next time keep on clipping on
[Music]
I don't know why they're applauding
Krampus that was what's wrong with you
people that was awful oh really because
it made me hungry Krampus Krampus you
are not gonna eat that baby what of
course not I wouldn't dare this is my
therapy baby you see wait a minute
therapy baby yes I get nervous in front
of crowds now this this is my meal baby
oh for God's sake
yeah totally different is it anyone want
to join me
no no Krampus nobody wants to join you
now Andy Andy you're not gonna eat a
baby I I don't like to be rude to guests
though he's pretty big baby is plenty
for all of them we're gonna take a
little break the Krampus everybody Andy
no you're not eating a baby right
[Applause]
you